see on your screen the reception desk
here on the third floor where the
reporters sit and do their job every day
as John Kelly with a camera on his
shoulder walks back toward our set want
to ask the first question of Arthur
souls burger jr. what's the best thing
in your own personal opinion about this
newspaper what a challenging question of
the quality of the men and women with
whom you're working is the best thing
the quality of the minds the quality of
the commitment to to what it is we do
both on the business side and and on the
new side our production is circulation
people who work so valiantly to get out
that great paper that we produced enough
in the wake of the tragedy of September
11th the quality of their of their
vision and their and their love of scope
that there's not a subject of involving
human endeavor that you can't find an
expert on in this building in this
newsroom that's the greatest challenge
and the greatest fun of this 23 years
with the New York Times your family has
on his paper roughly for how long a
little over century 100 years plus 100
years and counting the last time we did
this show back at the 100th anniversary
you're about to do color that's right
that's right and now color is here but
this is the first time we've ever
allowed television live Colin shows in
this newsroom why did you let us do this
well because of course we love you so
much of course it was a personal thing
it wouldn't have been for anybody else
because television is a part of our
future when we last talked we were on
the verge of producing the next
generation of the New York Times a 6
section 7 section or eight sometimes
color newspaper printed throughout the
country with Prince sites scattered
around the United States and that took
us 10 years to get from where we had
been through to that to that day and the
as soon as we finished that ten-year
plan we we began our next we're now in
in the middle of that and it's
ambivalent agnostic as to means of
distribution we know television is got
to be an important part of our future
and you're seeing us move more and more
of our reporting on to tell
science times for example is now a
television program we do specials for
rush everything from A&E to Showtime to
PBS so we're getting more comfortable
with television it's part of our future
and we thought we might as well bring it
to us front page of the sep tember 12
edition 2001 big headline us attacked
where were you when this happened I was
in my office planning for a party that
my wife and I have we're going to give
that night for the incoming executive
editor the incoming managing editor the
incoming editorial page editor when that
plane hit I called Howell and I said I
think the party's off we had no idea of
the scope of the story at that point we
all thought a small plane had
accidentally hit the World Trade Center
the next 24 hours and quite frankly next
two weeks were just the most intense
period of journalism I've ever
participated in and and then as soon as
we got our sea legs on that story we
started to get the anthrax scares Judy
Miller opens that envelope the next
thing you know FBI CDC people are
wandering around this newsroom and space
suits and worse so it's been it's been a
it's been a tough and demanding rod what
was your personal reaction to the
bombing I think what all of us must have
felt at first disbelief it really just
couldn't be happening second a real
sense of horror concern for friends and
family we are blessed that the New York
Times newspaper and the new york times
company didn't lose any of its its men
and women in this in this tragedy but
many of us lost loved ones children
parents siblings and then and perhaps
this is the the nature of the business
we're in a real sense that we could best
serve our community by by engaging in
journalism that in any situation but
most importantly something like this
our duty is to is to our readers into
the American public because they're
going to be making some very difficult
decisions over the next days weeks
months and they've got to do it on the
base of information that's trustworthy
here's the front page of this Friday
November 30th 2001 edition all the
stories basically are about this on the
above the fold president defends
military tribunals and terrorist cases
groups gird for long legal fight on new
bush anti-terror powers all in police
department face counseling and militias
from South closing it on talibans last
major bastion how has your paper changed
what have you done new and different
we've done new and different a new
section of course a nation challenged is
has was appearing really from the first
day on that's a significant commitment
of resources at a time of fun some
somewhat difficult economic conditions
and then we decided to take it from a
nation challenged to a reader challenged
I don't know if you have our upside down
sports section there but we lost our
sports section front to create the
nation challenge section so we reversed
on the back of our Metro section is an
upside down sports page which has caused
some humorous comment in the in The New
Yorker magazine one of the great
cartoons in The New Yorker magazine is
due to this it has a a wife reading the
Metro section like that like this and
our husband sitting upside down in the
chair where you would be reading the
sports section but I mean for the
audience what is what you do is you pick
up first time you pick it up you think
there's a mistake yeah you see the Metro
section here and in order to get the
sports section you actually literally
flip it up like that why'd you do that
we did that so that people could still
be reading it going inside out the the
traditional way turning the pages from
left to right I guess but what's to put
the humor and of that actually pretty in
I think pretty good answer to a pretty
tricky question we had aside what we've
what we've what's really changed here
and I think it's changed in all american
news organizations is is is a sense of
mission in a sense of purpose a sense
that once
again news matters it's not God Gary
Condit it's it's what's happening in the
world around us it's the it's it's
focusing on some very broad and thematic
issues that are going to be troubling us
as a society world Society for a very
long time that we now have to grapple
with and its external in a sense of
what's happening in Afghanistan or the
Muslim world or the nature of of dual
societies this internal what's happening
in our society when we are under
conditions of stress how do we respond
do we respond in a way that enhances the
values that we we believe we hold and
that we we showed her the rest of the
world does it do we respond a way that
diminishes those values and I think
that's going to be a very important
discussion for this country for some
time to come Arthur Sulzberger Jr will
be with us for another 20 minutes the
phone lines are open the numbers are
there on the screen you can begin
downing right now we'll get you right on
and any subject is alright however we do
have the chairman of the New York Times
you might want to ask about how the
newspapers run or sep tember 11th and
how you see it I noticed on my bio sheet
and the background information that you
now have 207 markets nationwide let this
newspaper is delivered right how
expensive is that ah it's expensive
we're an expensive newspaper to produce
weird expensive newspaper from the
illness in terms of the size of our
newsroom which is on about 1,200 men and
women and in our in our distribution on
the other hand we're not expensive
newspaper to purchase as anyone who buys
the paper knows you pay for quality but
this is this is our future this is
actually our present to grow our paper
to make it more increasingly national to
make it available to as many people as
we possibly can now if so we have the
internet as well the internet edition of
the times is the largest newspaper own
internet site in the world so there are
places where you can't get the times in
print where you can still get access to
the information that we offer our
readers again the numbers on the screen
join us here this morning as we come to
you live from the new york times
newsroom we're on the third floor
how many floors of this building to
occupy well as we built this building
back in the term by nineteen ten or
twelve i'm going to guess we it's
totally our building and it's our
building for the moment we are building
a new headquarters about three blocks
from here designed by Renzo Piano the
italian architect that should be up and
running in 2005 and i look forward to
hosting you in our in that building a
few years from now now if you did a quiz
nationwide about where the name Times
Square came from how many people would
get the right answer I think about 5% it
was called longacre square until a dull
fox moved the new york times here in
1905 he built the building that they
dropped the ball from it New Year's Eve
in fact we did that first as a publicity
stunt back in around 1906 and it caught
on but I think most people don't recall
that that's the time squares name for
the times any more than they were called
at herald square his name for the new
york herald what do you read in the
morning besides the new york times oh
well I'd love to tell you that reading
the New York Times is a it takes up a
morning what I also read is the wall
street journal and I'll I'll check in
and out of a variety of other newspapers
but I don't read any other newspaper on
a regular basis USA TODAY's founder al
neuharth does a column every friday us
you read it ever no I well I have read
it on occasion yeah sure but this
morning he's talking about this whole
issue of the terrorists and justice and
he's talking about being at a dinner up
here for foreign journalists and he
asked John Seigenthaler what he thought
and Peter Pritchard who used to be the
editor but he says my view we certainly
must guard against crackdowns on Arab
Americans similar to what happened to
japanese-americans World War two but
when it comes to dealing with Osama bin
Laden and his hardcore cronies strictly
applying our traditional innocent until
proven guilty approach seems a bit
far-fetched what would you say to that I
was at that dinner um I couldn't agree
more with the first half let's start
with hat we've got to be awfully careful
about how we treat American citizens and
people who are living in this
tree citizens are not and I understand
his anger and to Ben Laden I feel it too
I think anyone who saw those towers
crumble is is mighty angry at at Ben
Laden and his and his and his cronies do
I believe in summary execution no would
I rather see bet bet what I like to see
metal Hutton captured I'm not sure let's
take some calls sacramento california on
the Democratic line for Arthur
Sulzberger Jr go ahead please good
morning Brian and good morning now
author i'm sorry i can't pronounce your
last name hope you don't mind me calling
you by your first not at all took me
about six years before i could pronounce
my lesson okay i don't feel so bad then
okay I I was going through some old
papers and I guess I a mere in
Sacramento and and I get the sacramental
be and going through some old papers and
I ran across a paper that dated July
sixteenth two months before the care of
attack and if it was printed out of your
paper the New York Times Larry see jobs
and former State Department collar
terrorism specialist and the article
that he wrote in the editorial is our
perception is wrong about terrorism and
it talks about how the know how the pit
the Pentagon the military changed their
their attentions from the Cold War you
know after the after the Cold War after
that everything out the evil empire
collapsed said that they turn their
attention from from from the Cold War to
terrorism and said that they were
looking here says says an intelligence
agencies that are desperate to find any
enemy to justify budget growth and it
speaks about hear about justify using
charity to justify anything
from building a little defense to
violating constitutional rights as in
the case of Arab Americans held in
prison without charge and I when I see
it I I was stunned because I hadn't read
this before and I'm saying well this was
written too much before so where did
they get this information it's thanks
caller appreciate it okay um I'm not
familiar with this piece and I'll enough
really that byline it it's possible I
was an op-ed page piece just a piece
written by an outside writer that
appeared on our op-ed page and was
picked up by by the sacramento bee
mcclatchy paper if i'm not mistaken and
a good one therefore it dear up add
pieces get transmitted on your water
anything that appears in The Times it
does get onto the new york times news
service which is the second largest news
service in the United States so it gets
why distribution um so I'm you know it's
a fascinating question you've asked and
I wish I had a better answer for you
then I do which is that huh I don't
recall that piece yeah are you surprised
I guess by what has happened I don't
send my problem I think all of us are
surprised I don't think any of us
expected to see this kind of action take
place and maybe that's a sign that that
we were a little asleep at the switch
clearly we were asleep at the switch as
a society in some degrees and I think
people have legitimately criticized the
New York Times and other newspapers for
in some cases not being as as as as as
focused on this as a critical issue as
we should have been for Arthur
salzburger jr. the New York Times
oceanside california on the Republican
line go ahead please well I was curious
because i was aware that afghanistan
were large producers or growers of
poppies which we all know the they had
the heroin production throughout the
world and i was wondering i haven't
heard any news about the poppy fields
there and have a disrupted production on
that or what's going on in a good
question actually the new york times did
carry a piece on that very subject a few
days ago
um we as much as we might hate the
Taliban and for for some good reasons
they actually did do a lot to to curb
the the growing of poppies and the
production of heroin now that they're no
longer in charge we're starting to
already see that is that that business
get back in a business and I guess to be
fair and I hate to say this if it's not
as all these folks feel that they have a
lot of choice there we all have seen
photos and and and and read news stories
about how poor the society is and
especially after these years and years
of dreadful civil wars uh this is about
the only cash crop they got left uh so
we've got to find a way to get them off
of that but yes there was a story in The
Times about the how this is again coming
coming back how many reporters over in
that area of the world from the New York
town in that area of the world I I can
tell you it's over to over a dozen in
Afghanistan between reporters and
photographers and I got got to tell you
I am as nervous as can be about their
safety we've all seen those dreadful
stories about about journalists shot in
in their bedrooms in their bedrooms not
often you know on the front lines more
journalists have died so far in this in
this war than have European or American
soldiers and I'm very concerned about
the safety of our folks Warrenton
Virginia Democratic line good morning
yes good morning I wanted to compliment
the publisher on his newspaper I
subscribe to it I live in Virginia and I
get it I get it a day delayed but that's
okay I think your newspaper is one of
the last independent newspapers in the
country and I the last ones that do
investigative reporting I wonder if
you're going to have any more on the
carlyle group good question well first
of all thank you very much I appreciate
that and um if i'll try to get it build
an ex printing plant closer to your home
so you don't have to wait a day for
these she get that from Washington she
would get that probably from the
Washington print site yeah although we
just put one up in
North Carolina and gastonia that may
that may be better able to server
depending on where Virginia Sheila's uh
the carlyle group is a is a fascinating
uh and powerful investment firm based
out of Washington uh and as far as I
know there's nothing in the worst on
that but quite frankly the people who
know better than that are going to be
sitting in this seat shortly in howell
rains or Gerald Boyd who really are
responsible for the news coverage on
their page on your editorial page today
there are three editorials as there are
usually most days russian oil power is
the lead editorial did you have anything
to say about that and on a normal day do
you have much to say about what
eventually becomes the editorial policy
this paper oh no I often oh I generally
open up the editorial page and and see
the editorials for the first time Gail
Collins who's our edit or new editorial
page editor and I have lunch every
Wednesday um in fact Howell reigns
Gerald Boyd Gail Collins Janet Robinson
and I the five of us who are really
responsible for running the New York
Times newspaper have lunch every
Wednesday so where we stay in touch on
issues and she knows the issues that are
particular concern to me and she also
knows that if we're going to be changing
our policy if we're going in a new
direction then that's a discussion
beforehand but if we're just commenting
on that on the events in the in a sort
of traditional times away she and Phil
baffi and Phil tottman the three folks
who are most responsible for the
editorial page have great license next
call for Arthur Schlesinger jr.
hiawassee Georgia go ahead please all
right Arthur Sulzberger Jr excuse me how
many times people like that mistake go
ahead hiawassee I get his mail I go
ahead please good morning can you hear
me yes um thanks for taking my call I'd
like to comment on the trial by military
tribunal versus our civil courts nowhere
does the press want to get into poles
anymore used to be when things were
controversial with the administration
and if there was any slight advantage
against the Bush administration hours a
day would be spent on polls showing them
on TV national TV on this particular
issue ninety percent of the country is
in favor of what the president's doing
twenty five to thirty percent of the
people don't think he's going far enough
and yet we hear all last night on
national networks how all of a sudden
there's this great controversy against
the president's decision you people just
don't get it how many more thousands of
lives have to be lost before you realize
the gravity of this situation and the
kind of people I don't even want to call
them people the kind of animals that
we're dealing with in this situation
thanks caller I'm not sure what there
was a question in the air but i'll see
if i can turn one into it I look at
polling i think but first of all I think
he's suggesting that the newspapers and
the media care more about this Tribunal
issue than the public at large I don't
know I don't know if that's true or not
true I suspect it's not um I don't know
where those numbers came from ninety
percent I i mean the the the issue
polling is of course a tricky one
because as we all know poles can be
manipulated in extraordinarily easy ways
and unless your polling organization is
committed to producing a that honest and
fair polls you can skew it anyway you
watch us by the way you phrase the
question so when I hear a number like
ninety percent this I'm making an
assumption that's not a was not a fair
Pole this is a complex issue and it gets
to the very nature of our democracy and
the issue of rule by law this is not to
prejudge the outcome it's to say that
there are values that we we have in
tarrant in our in our structure in as a
country and when we and in cases like
this there's real value in having the
discussion in the debate and I don't
think the president would disagree with
that our story in today's paper is about
the president engaging in that
discussion and debate and we're
reporting it
uh so I hear what the what the caller
said I as a former present would say I
feel your anger but as angry as we are
and I share that anger in a very very
fundamental way as angry as we are
there's a reason that we have trial by
jury in this country not summary
execution mr. salzburger was educated at
tufts university graduated 1974 had his
master's granted to him in 1985 worked
for The Associated Press first job 76-78
and you mentioned for we went on your
first story in The New York Times was
with a byline from the AP right
surprised it was an AP story i was at AP
reporter in Europe at the time and it
was a story about a train station
hostage I need to correct you I did not
get my Master's I went to three three
months of the harvard business school so
it was not quite a harvard business goes
program for management develop that's I
know that was long so that I could read
a balance sheet let's go to Baltimore
Maryland next for the call go ahead
please you're on with Arthur souls
burger jr. good morning a good morning
gentlemen the question I have concerns a
fascinating piece that I read as part of
the times is one hundred and fiftieth
anniversary Jose article by Max Frankel
the s former editor concerning the times
is rather woeful coverage of the
Holocaust during world war two and
basically the crux of the the piece was
that what many now consider you know one
of the most horrific examples of
inhumanity certainly the 20th century
was covered virtually almost
non-existent ly by the times during the
war and I'm just wondering whether the
current publisher when did you first
realize that sort of the times had
dropped the ball and one of the most
important stories of that century and
was it something that was ever discussed
the over the family table
um uh first of all I I gotta tell you I
was enormously proud that this paper ran
that piece that max rankle who was
executive editor here the first
executive editor I ever worked with his
publisher I had written it um and and
Max as many people don't know was a
refugee at a Jewish refugee of Nazi
Germany Max and his family so this was
in a very important story I'm not going
to get into what we discussed around the
family table it is after all family but
I can tell you that at the times for
many years we've we've all that we've
acknowledged this uh I remember reading
a book by a woman I think they Deborah
lips lips like perhaps on how the
Holocaust was covered it was many years
ago now and and it's a little more
nuanced I think then you've just
described it in fact the the failure of
coverage and it was an enormous failure
was hidden by the fact that we did
report it we just we reported it in
snippets we kept it off the front page
we never put the pieces together we
didn't do journalism and it was a huge
failure on our part and on the part of
all of the American media uh not to take
away from the blame from the times we
were then the preeminent paper in this
country as we are today and when there's
no excuse for so we're human and we make
mistakes and what I loved about about
this special section and that story in
this special section is our willingness
to step up to that and to it and to
acknowledge this perhaps greatest
failure in our in our in our 150 years
our in-depth program on Sunday at 12
News east coast time on c-span 2 is
David McCullough for three hours your
calls will dominate that program join us
if you have an interest in John Adams
and Truman and other books and he is as
written your family kids to how old
they're both in college where do they go
ah
well my son was at the University of
Tasmania first semester he's just flying
back this this Saturday so I haven't
seen him for six months at both the
brown and how about your father how is
he he's not in college he is not in
college on hell he's doing great what is
he dying retire he's the chairman
emeritus of the of the times he's still
on our Board of Directors he has an
office on the 11th floor of this
building which by the way to answer your
question earlier as 15 stories at all ah
and he comes in to work every every
every day Cleveland Ohio Democratic line
for Arthur Sulzberger Jr good morning oh
yes good morning I've since the
Whitewater steric story was saw
fabricated by you guys at the New York
Times Jefferson the lady in the Arkansas
completely ignored her documented papers
that she did ask Madison guarantee that
close two years earlier than the
government asked them to do you think
your old American people in apology and
not only you but the rest of the
newspapers that followed this completely
Hulk story and it worth to me it was
done for one reason and that was the
step on the Clintons message so you
couldn't pass health care and not only
that phony scandal but the rest of the
phony scandals in the New York Times was
the leader of the pack at that time do
you think thank you thanks car you know
it almost sounds quaint doesn't it now
cuz I don't I apologized for that to you
whoever you were calling it I don't mean
to dismiss your concern but it's it's in
the midst of this new world and this new
challenges that we face it just sounds
quaint um I'll tell you what I I'm I'm
being a lot smarter to let Howell reigns
answer that question if this caller is
allowed to add to react it because he's
more in touch with that news story by
far than I am I don't think we made it
up to let me get that on the table
quickly I don't think we made it up why
anyone would think we wanted to stop the
Clinton health care plan when we
editorialized in favor of it
I don't know but clearly somebody does
so you know they what you've now seen
sort of the yin and the yang of the joy
of this job there are people out there
convinced we were trying to smother the
Clinton administration and its message
there people out there who works
convinced we're trying to smother the
Bush administration and its message and
in truth what you're seeing here is is
how how people view our coverage through
their own political lens filter it in
such a way that it meets their needs and
then you know come back and call me we
start out by talking about television in
the future the New York Times what can
we expect to see from this newspaper in
the television world in the future well
I can tell you what I'd love to get to
I'd love to get to a New York Times
channel we we produce we believe the
finest news report in the world we know
that we can do this in the well and in
print and we know we can do it on the
web and we know that broadband is coming
which means that we have this third leg
of the stool to build which is
television and the ability to do what
we're doing right now we have a lot to
learn in that world we've got and we've
partnered with people to do that and
we're going to be doing things on our
own and we'll make mistakes and we'll
get things right and will grow and we'll
learn but those three streams of
distribution are really going to come
together at some point in our lives and
the x is going to have to have the
skills and the abilities to do this as
well as we do as well as we do print of
the internet let's go to Southport
Connecticut on Republican line X for
Arthur Salisbury jr. good morning good
morning how are you um I have a question
about the change by the New York Times
of its motto from from all the news
that's fit to print which imposes a
responsibility to everything you want to
know or everything you ought to know
it's one of the other
uh and I want to know why that that
happened now i do see you're showing me
that it's all the news that's fit to
print is there but also was changed i am
I correct about that mr. Salzberg no
actually I thought I'm a little baffled
by the question um no that's our motto
all of this is that to print a doll Fox
my great grandfather created it and I
would be hung in effigy by my family if
I even attempt it to to change to change
it to anything else and furthermore I
have no desire to I believe in it uh you
may be referring to an advertising
slogan that we are using uh and and that
may be something you're seeing but no
let me be clear our motto and
advertising slogans adapt and change
from whatever it might be at the moment
to what what was a great one during the
60s I got my Java the new york times to
other things our motto is all the news
that's fit to print and that's not going
to change san antonio texas your next go
ahead please yes after apologize for the
fact i've got a bad cold i just walked
up and I saw this apparition on on the
screen I got two points number one is I
what I was going to college I remember
they New York Times soft pedaled the
Holocaust considerably now you swung
chat pendulum all the way on the other
side I could say one thing here the
terrorist best friend and I can't
understand I kind of dislike your
sissified approach to things get real
get in the real world we're fighting for
a life and you're in your little
paddling about the thing Wow but okay I
got your 55 got your point there was a
I'm sorry you tuned in late we actually
did talk about the Holocaust coverage a
little bit earlier in this program and
there was a gentleman I think from
California who who feels the same way
you do but a terrorist best friend
not likely and I'm sorry you feel that
way uh you know it's an interesting
issue that all news organizations are
dealing with right now of where our
patriotism and our journalistic
responsibilities meet and I'm not going
to pretend that the New York Times
uniquely has the answer or any other
news organizations who are all
struggling with this this newspaper and
the Washington Post in the LA Times and
The Wall Street Journal all come from
the same miliar the American system we
believe in it desperately we are
products of it we couldn't survive in
another system the First Amendment and
capitalism are critical to our
well-being so does that happen the other
half is we are we are journalists and
our job is not to print propaganda
because a map because this country is
going to make some tough and critical
decisions and in our democracy the
informed electorate an informed
electorate is the critical component of
keeping democracy alive it's not a
secret that an awful lot of people from
here to Washington pick up this
newspaper every day and the television
business read your paper and duplicated
on the evening news it's not a secret
that people in the newspaper business
follow your lead you set the priorities
do you sense that do you talk about that
and that does it matter to you of course
we sense it and we see it and yes it
matters to us it matters to us because
it means that the that what we do as
greater import we are human we make
mistakes we air but we never don't take
our responsibility with the greatest of
seriousness our readers and our readers
and viewers and whatever you call them
on the Internet are the most engaged
readership you could ever hope to have
they're very much like your viewers in
fact I suspect your readers and our
viewers are termed
tremendous overlap they hold us
accountable they demand excellence and
they and they deserve what they deserve
our best and we never lose sight of that
last call for our guests san diego
california on the Democratic line good
morning good morning and i was calling
really then is the follow-up to what you
just said the New York Times I always
understood was America's newspaper and
it does set the agenda a lot for the
electronic media it seems to me having
been a subscriber for 10 to 12 years and
i truly value its coverage of foreign
and domestic affairs but i had two
points and it was something of a
follow-up to an earlier call mr.
salzburger said it was quaint that we
should get into this but I almost the so
angry with the new york times editorial
policy regarding the former president
and how they nitpicked and and treating
him what I regard is in a very ugly
fashion over a lot of stuff that seemed
to have little import or anything to do
with the presidency that was my first
point and the second point is the
coverage of the whitewater meet being
the paper of record it started that
train out of the station figuratively
speaking with that article by Jeff girth
which I think was bad reporting all
right your thanks well when I heard was
San Diego is sort of hoping was my
mother calling she lives there uh again
how old rains will be here he can talk a
lot more he was editorial page editor in
those years then and I can't I just like
to say this if you look at our
editorials and you look at the at the
Clinton policies putting aside his human
issues you see a tremendous overlap this
we this was a president we supported
twice on our editorial page for election
and we were committed i think even more
so than he was at times to the policies
that he enunciated at the time did we
have problems with him as an individual
absolutely but if you separate those
from the way he was behaving as I from
his policy issues I think you'll find
the times than he
great alignment last question to you I
suspect that if some of your reporters
could get to you today they would and
say exactly what they think they say why
did you let television cameras in this
newsroom this is a sacred place we never
have to deal with anything like this
what would you tell him first of all
we're behind we're beyond that it's been
clear for the last four years that
television was going to be an important
part of our future I've said that to the
staff in numerous occasions we are doing
television our reporters are doing
television we're past the point of
saying this is a medium that diminishes
news we believe we have something we can
bring to television and these reporters
are going to be the ones who do it and
the ones we're hiring with more TV
experience but I think the days where we
are going to look down on television are
behind us this is a medium we will
grapple with and grapple with
successfully so I think that you're
you're thinking about the past and you
were right about the past ah but whether
they whether individual journalists want
it or not this is where we're going our
guest has been the chairman and
publisher of The New York Times Arthur
salzburger jr. thanks a lot for letting
us do this thank you